my guest tonight of course a very
talented actor who played schmidt
on new girl he can currently be seen
starring in the neighborhood
on cbs and the movie promising young
woman which is in theaters and on demand
and it is absolutely amazing uh let's
take a look
i just thought that you were drunk yeah
really drunk
yeah well i'm not but that's good isn't
it
i think you should leave oh now you want
me to leave
no i just i'm really high
like i'm really high right now i don't
know what i'm doing
i think you should go but a second ago
you were determined for me to stay
you were pretty insistent actually i was
a nice guy
are you i thought we had a connection i
guess
a connection okay
what do i do for a living
sorry maybe that one's too hard how old
am i
how long have i lived in the city
what are my hobbies
what's my name
okay i'm a little confused max
greenfield is here
max that was christopher mintz platz
that's you're not in that clip no no
i just i'm very supportive of his work
[Laughter]
and i insisted that you guys showcase it
uh-huh because i've seen this movie uh
this is a
terrific and powerful film yeah you are
in this film
as is christopher minceplatz uh and i'm
glad that you're a fan
well you know i i mean let's talk about
chris's turn on this film
[Laughter]
is this what you do you just like to go
on and you know paul rudd does this too
he comes on my show and he shows a clip
that's not
his and it's been no i know paul shows
it from a totally different story i know
but i love that you've taken a new turn
on it which is i'll show a clip from the
movie i'm in
just it won't have me in the clip that's
it well it's
it's just how unselfish i am conan
wow i've always heard that about you
thank you
that's that's what i'm known for and now
i'm just i'm taking it i'm stepping it
up a notch
wow and uh you know if i'm ever in
something
i just i want to showcase the other
people right you know i'm sure he's
thrilled
i'm sure he's told that they're out
there pushing we're all thrilled to
watch him
where are you right now are you
obviously we're i'm in an abandoned
theater
you are in your home beautiful painting
behind you thank you this is the love a
lovely artist
a friend of ours john brown um
he's the king yeah we i am in my home
[Music]
i mm-hmm tell you now that at any moment
a dog or a child could interrupt our
conversation or if you hear noises
that's just what
right it's okay i've been dealing with
that and uh
and we welcome it sometimes it's
delightful and kind of cute and
sometimes it's just
you know sometimes when someone says my
son may interrupt
it's cute when it's like a three or four
year old when
it's a 32 year old son who never
who never moved out of the house it just
gets sad
but it's also been 10 months of this and
i think we'll pass the cute point
i think we are uh so much to talk about
uh i've
encountered you uh several times in the
past and i always go out of my way to
tell you how
i'm a big fan of yours we all are in my
family because you're such a funny
performer
you're a hilarious performer and i feel
a little bad because
um normally if you were on my show
i would provide some kind of gift
because that's what we try to do
on these talk shows you know and today
it's just a zoom call and nothing
no mug you get nothing you get nothing
well you know i you know your show is
one of the shows where i really i don't
come for the mug
i want to be with you and i and i love
andy and
i'm such big fans of your of you guys
you know
when you talk about um having watched
new girl now with your kids and yeah and
and sort of discovering it and you've
said some very flattering things to me
um it's it's it's very uncomfortable for
me to hear because i remember
going on your show for the first time
and being like i don't know how to do
this show
these are two of the funniest human
beings on earth
and you know i think our instinct when
you're around people that you know
are just hands down funnier you that is
just to be quiet
well you i remember you being uh very
delightful and very funny
um i remember you uh complaining a bit
about the gifts
i'm curious about something who of the
talk show hosts who has the best swag
when you go visit well so
great question um
colbert for sure um yeah now colbert
like you don't want to schlep to new
york to do a talk show
right um but colbert you sort of do
because you you know what you're going
to receive when you get to your dressing
room
yes actually i should let me take that
back you don't know what you're going to
receive
you just know that it's going to be
great i'll say this
i'll say this about steven's show this
is my experience um
the last time i went on that show and i
walked into my room
i thought that i had won a game show
there was
uh there was electronics
there was a fur coat uh floor length
um just incredible stuff and i got very
self-conscious because i realize when
people come on our show
there's a mug that i i don't even think
it's a mug for our show
i think it's a mug from alf from the
like 1980s
and then uh we give them some popcorn
some like government-issued popcorn
so i felt horrible because they really
go all out
my cap's off to those people it feels
like you're being re-gifted
things that stephen colbert received
[Laughter]
and you say to yourself man steven's got
to move my knife
what we do at our show is i uh
we hoard stuff that we get from steven's
show that other people haven't used
and we hang on to it and mostly food so
it's food that we're giving away that's
from colbert's
guest room and it's like four years old
but
yeah but it's also like a beautiful
nantucket chocolate
i know it's not fair it's not fair and
uh
you know once again uh that man that man
i loathe him
um but he knows that that's another
reason
[Laughter]
hey you know you mentioned um your
family
and how they're around and they're
hanging around the house
i have two children they're older than
your kids my kids are
uh you know sort of mid-teen age years
your kids are how old uh
our daughter is just about to turn 11 um
and our son is five
okay here's a question i have my kids at
17 and 15 their schoolwork
is way beyond my comprehension now if
it's history i can maybe help them out a
little bit or english
but in math and sciences i'm humiliated
because if first of all they would never
go to me for help
but in no way can i comprehend what
they're studying
is your daughter at that level yet
oh it's i mean she was at that level
three years ago
[Laughter]
does um uh i know that uh
your daughter is she does she like
reading is she a reader
no um she she is not
um yeah
she's not a reader and um i remember
having a conversation with her and she
was like
or and she was telling me she i knew she
didn't like to read and i was explaining
to her
right look the only way to get better
at reading is to read
and she fired back at me immediately and
she was like well is that why you're so
bad at guitar because you don't play it
[Laughter]
and i said i play
all the time and
it really it it stung me in a way
yeah because uh she wasn't saying it to
be a burn it sounded like
she was just being honest about your
guitar playing
in a way that she it also was one of
those
like left hooks that you just don't see
coming yeah
where you go look i'm trying to help you
and guide you through this as a parent
and she's just like oh yeah and the
response was so natural and honest
and so biting and affected me
emotionally and my ego
in such a way it really
it was a tough one for me to swallow
because i'm just learning i started
playing guitar
like two years ago two years if you
started
if you've only been doing it for two
years you can't be hard on yourself
i am i am i want to be good so bad
yeah i don't know do you because you
play quite a bit
i'm assuming that you're that you're in
a position where you'll have to play i
think i've seen you have having to play
where where you're with you know slash
or something or
yeah i've had i've had the opportunity
to play with people
uh you know who really
uh who do it for a living that's very
humbling like if i played
the times i've played with like a jack
white or
a beck or you know um you know billy
gibbons or anyone like that
i decide to as much as possible just
stick with rhythm
just stick with rhythm and every now and
then
um if i get it's almost like i can feel
my ego
getting the better of me and then i'll
step out and i'll try a little bit of
lead and quickly remember
i'm a comedian
this is not what i should be doing so
uh yeah i um rhythm
just just stay in the pocket do rhythm
and uh
and and try not to i try not to expose
myself as this hack amateur you know
yeah i'll tell you a horrible story i my
daughter is friendly with
um tom morello's child oh wow
and they go to school together and i'm
sure you know tom
yeah he is one of the all-time coolest
human beings
on earth great guy and an insane
guitarist yeah
and then also one of the greatest guitar
players of all time
so you know our kids are playing
together and they're always in like some
sort of sport and we're on the
sideline watching and i just see him
quite a bit
um and my relationship with him predates
me
learning how to play guitar and so i
picked it up on the show and as soon as
i started really getting into it i
really got into it right and was so
excited
and had seen tom a couple times and all
of a sudden internally my relationship
to him changed and um
i started looking at him in a much
different way so envious and
and and and aware that the connection
that we had
um was not a real one but
anyway i'm sitting with him one day
and i made a note to myself mentally
never to bring up
that i play guitar right or that i'm
just starting to learn
and we're sitting there we're talking we
sort of run out of conversation there's
not
anything left and you know clearly we're
still going to be standing there
and in a real moment of weakness i said
uh
well tom you're never going to believe
this but and it just
came but i just started playing guitar
and as soon as as soon as i said it i
knew it was a mistake yeah you're like
i'm a bit of a
just so you know uh you're not the only
guitar you're not the only guitarist in
the room
i play a little as well yeah it was so
bad
yeah so bad and i could he and i he was
so nice about it
but it also was devastating and then
i you know i was like i felt bad for the
rest of the day
i was like beating like really beating
myself up and then
much later i'd say i don't know
a month or so later i see him outside
the school and he's sort of walking
and we're passing each other and in this
moment of greeting
he sort of goes hey man
how's the uh guitar
[Laughter]
yeah i want to make sure that i i talk
about promising young woman
because yes please uh this movie
there's and it's a cliche to say there's
a lot of buzz about this movie
there truly is uh so much chatter
about this film and um
i think it's a very hard film to
categorize it's mesmerizing it's
fantastic
all the performances are great uh
and it feels like a very important movie
and
at the same time there are moments that
i thought were very funny and then of
course
there are moments that are really
harrowing and heartbreaking and it's
just beautifully done
it's really beautifully done yeah
emerald fennel who wrote and directed it
um she is
unbelievable um she had written the
script and i remember reading the script
and being like i don't know
i'm not even sure what the tone is of
this movie um
and i thought and and then she they'd
cast a bunch of people like
christopher vince plotz and and adam
brody and all these sort of comedic
actors and i thought
what is like i i really didn't
understand what because it didn't
totally read
right um and then i had a conversation
with her
and i was so blown away and she was so
focused and had such a clear vision of
what this thing was supposed to be
and really executed everything on every
level and i remember seeing the movie
and going oh my
oh my goodness and the reason we can't
we could show a clip of me in the movie
it's a spoiler which i swear i'm in yeah
uh is a spoiler
and yeah it it really um
and i i just can't say enough about her
and yeah and
the same goes for carrie mulligan who's
amazing
kerry milligan is great but i also think
there was a decision
and when people see the movie they'll
understand but
uh you know bo burnham's in it all these
and
and and you are casting it and what what
happens is you get
so many very funny likeable
guys that we already know and like and
think are funny
and then they're put in this context
that uh
almost takes advantage of the fact that
we're familiar with you
and we like you and turns it it turns it
on it on its head which i thought was
very powerful
yeah you know there's there's been an
interesting reaction
some people totally get it and then
there are other people who watch the
movie specifically with
with uh you know the scenes that i'm in
and think i don't understand why you
would
put somebody like max from the movie
yeah because
uh this scene is so dramatic why would
you take a
a comedic actor and put him in there it
somehow makes the scene almost come
across
comedic well i was blown away by this
movie
people should watch it promising young
woman is now in theaters
and available uh at home on demand
and people should watch it and i think
people will watch it because the word of
mouth is
insane plus new episodes of the
neighborhood air mondays
on cbs are you guys able to be shooting
that now
or is it is it still impossible yeah
we're yeah we're back up we
we've been really fortunate that we'd be
able to do the show and um
we're we've shot quite a few episodes at
this point
that's great it's really exciting so
hopefully we can finish that out
um and it's been wonderful
that's great thank you very much for
doing this i so appreciate it
and thank you for making a gift of that
painting behind you just have it sent to
my home
look at that oh you you can get one do
colbert i'm sure it'll be there